you
alright 51 players in this one I imagine
more will enter soon enough let's see
how round one goes ok hmm speedy
speediness
um speediness reason doctor chairman all
right let's try round two round two
let's just wait for round two
there we go
there we go
now the first real game has begun
already we're gonna chop there we're
gonna break pins we're gonna get to open
files and get castled of course get in
d5 we're there I'm gonna bully that
night gonna keep on pushing where's that
night gonna go strike at a two and maybe
think about e3 and made on g2 uh-huh
let's throw a punch at the night all
right let's go there
oh we're gonna we're gonna kick this guy
around a bit I think he's gonna be
flushed back break down the light
squares h3 and then there and I rook is
close to trapped isn't he
smash through an f2 Queen d2 bishop here
take the knight after the Queen goes
somewhere there we go
now we're gonna return with the Queen
strike it f2 no no it's actually guard
some dark squares tuck the king in all
right let's come back I lied
push through
breakdown the B file I could do that
grab a pond I don't have any time their
bishops cooked no stalemates no
stalemates and they're down a time - all
right
76 players in this one let's try a four
stay away from Knight to f3 what am i
doing
stay away from Knight to f3 and instead
mouse slip a Knight to e2 you could try
that sometime there we go we're gonna
make it work
Knight g3 to h5 maybe will upend the
night I get to take there with check and
live dangerous on f2 oh they didn't take
they could have I was gonna run the d1
cuz the only square I could have run to
Bishop g5 Queen g6 would have been a
little bit of bother
let's hit the Queen let's now develop
here f6 I could take multiple ways this
seems to be pretty juicy that's gonna
work it might have been something better
but at the very least I'm getting the
Queen now let's make sure I get rid of
the knight could have also taken the
pawn let's do this first and continue
pushing now I will take the knight that
way the bishop can't recapture alright
we're gonna look for the old rook up and
over sack on h7 and then we're
threatening turning to take here now
they're kind of in a pickle
mmm who cares about the be fun I'm just
gonna triple up not gonna cash out just
yet hang on they might do something
sneaky on you for No all right we got
for a bunch of fours on board the foe
let's go it's Knight f3 there you go
again I can't shake that man can I say
got it get rid of that Knight f3 first
move it's garbage for these Bullock
games not really but I just feel like I
should be going with more aggressive
stuff and I that's cooking side minority
attacks stuff lookit look at this you
minority attacker no ok they do have
that square we're still gonna shoot for
this they get the a file I've broken
down their structure okay they didn't
take I think they should have to give
themselves the a file now we're going to
reposition our knight to this square I'm
fine with Bishop takes Knight this is a
very good home I've also taken the C
pawn I didn't have a good reason not to
do that don't forget about the a pond
deep on is now vulnerable and will be
one take them light square weaknesses
let's improve the rook let's grab a pawn
there's no good discovery by the knight
offer a queen exchange otherwise I'm
getting a mate to I could even take with
the pawn go here here next I want a cup
King off now it's running this they got
a Duke here they didn't
that's mate sixteen nine eight eight all
right let's go with the East six Bishop
d7 Queen's Indian land here we go Castle
yeah that was a mistake on my part
wasn't it is he gonna get trapped not
quite here all right now I'm gonna get
c5 in hmm and I guess I got I give up my
dark square Bishop huh hmm they made it
they should have taken there it's coming
back I should have gone with the other
rook but they're gonna play c5 could do
this now they're they're still in that
pin also I could have taken their night
that would have been better take that
night I'm on it again all right now they
have to be careful I have my rooks in a
good spot I'm looking for a Knight g5
just to trade maybe insert g6 first and
a sac here just one exchange mm-hmm
let's just come over here I want to
guard my dark squares Queen f6 King g7
where's
time I know it at the Queen exchange huh
six seconds oh I'm down at time oh man
why didn't I go faster that one man 16
what am I saying 1626 is in top sort of
Bishop g2
let's get castled oh man I felt like I
could have gone faster why wasn't I
going faster than that one the
light-square bishop here we go come on
now get a 5 that pawn moves all right
now things are getting serious Queen
takes f5 be more direct
no more positional miss give checks look
for mates take free pieces and maybe get
another Queen huh
night a for take advantage the pinned
piece where's the mate made on b7 give a
check
there we go back to tournament I'm on
page 2 I have 10 15 minutes left this is
a 26 minute tournament okay
they have this guy in third is the one
that our fourth now he's the one that
gave me a beating okay and going with
this are we try a snake benoni this
rookie are fast and maybe pin the night
no connect nights
to get my Knight to g6 you know hits
with tempo I want my other night here
9075 although this can hit right now no
they didn't do it
v6 don't want it uh yeah they're gonna
play Bishop to a4 they could have okay
how to capture we go with the pawn
otherwise f4 I guess not the best block
hater for sure we're gonna give it a go
you know they're not going to give up
their queen okay
my Knights gonna be kicked soon maybe I
could get them to d6 actually let's try
to hold on to my dark squares 96 yeah
they're preparing Bishop there get this
pawn break in making some progress
that's a check these guys continue to
advance their Bishop is not playing the
rook is restricted I guess here will
take with the night
stop that pawn from going any further I
played pretty fast in this one I don't
know let's make it simple
they're down on time okay twelve I'm at
twelves where's this guy at I'm
forgetting of the numbers here there I
go at night f3 forgetting that the
numbers show where you're at currently
in the in the tournament I'm in 13th
this guy's in 4/4 I rook d1 maybe I
could get a timely Knight move with the
discovered attack against the bishop
I want that night to move how this
wouldn't even be leading to me kind of
just poking around a little bit with
these moves they've weakened f5 a little
bit okay they're getting the a file hmm
let's get my knight back into play let's
just defend here stop the rook from
entering 31 seconds I'm hesitant to play
b4 and because I we can see four I had
this covered with my knight actually
clean check I don't think is leading to
anything let's go here stopping this
shattering type move in fact I can look
forward and I thought at least to b6 I
guess here okay we're gonna have a queen
exchange oh they thought I was gonna
take with the rook and he made a boo-boo
421 is in first 18 17 16 w young I gotta
get this guy back from the cyma this is
the guy who gave me a beating and not
only Sai Mele more than just the cyma
okay g3 is weakened okay where are the
mates Bishop there it may have been a
good move they moved I didn't see it
not see that one have a good night move
yeah sure give up a piece fortunately I
have that move that was a look what I
found move huh it's dropping
it's dropping again it's not taking it
means hit maybe I could do something
dangerous
like give me oh man unbelievable
unbelievable that was I still start with
Knight f3 stop doing that man do
something other than Knight f3 that was
like so random yeah let's just give me a
one you know or we could have a you know
what am I trying to say
you could do one of those yeah let's
weaken a square and you know maneuver a
knight you could do that to be a
maneuver I was ready to drop my queen
let's ask their queen a question there
we go
all right King come on over to d1 move
forward would you quit you're backing up
stuff you're done backing up no you're
not I can't defend this grad I want to
allow a knight here I guess I have to
retreat all right Knight here a past in
you you're close to cooked no he's gonna
land a fork yeah take one right away
that helped me a little bit
I get asked we're here for my night okay
no we're gonna crack open position a
little bit
how about Bishop right here my knight
controls this square which is nice let's
break this structure down a little bit I
have this square covered I'm not I'm not
afraid should I be where's that night
going I only have four seconds my night
is an animal man he was used really an
animal oh that's gonna hurt got windmill
action going on there down on time
46 24 22 I'm in second somehow that
happened quick
okay this guy's flying okay
surprised to see a speed bump Bertha
this is the guy that beat me up
alright Bertha I'm looking for my
redemption okay I'm just gonna castle
there's no fear no fear ninety-five
there you go
you got this you know you're gonna do
one of them and I'm gonna take your
night out and maybe look for this
aggressiveness ig4 got a babysit stuff
first
it comes a wild night don't be so quick
to move though night something bad might
happen probably trap my cream queen here
no I want to crash through on h2 let's
go here I guess
too crazy probably
in check I could go here and on that
check I could just lose material how are
we doing with that move whoo looking
good it's not looking good yeah my
cleanest toast
I can resign this that was very bad very
very bad and this guy's in first
somebody who had 46 somehow lost points
amazing amazing you could actually lose
points in the tournament Wow
you have to be a really special person
to do that a very very special person
someone someone who enjoys disrespecting
this great game that's the kind of
person age seven back to tournament 30
26 22 less than five I'm coming for you
Bertha watch out
you got me twice but I'm still around
sort of still playing the same stuff I
somehow cannot shake it you cannot get
it through my head to stop with this
silly Knight f3 move amazing amazing
we're gonna look at this move we're
gonna hang out of that guy he's
important and we're gonna cut the bishop
off
gonna give him a Boop we're gonna jump
in I thought he was a knight I thought
he was a knight Wow
fishing pole stuff alright Bishop get
out of there bishop c3b one bishop bunts
b12 c3 look at these dancing Knights
there we go bring the pain push here we
go
discoveries soon bishop takes here rook
here and then flush discoveries watch
out
where's a good one there's a good one
take you with check take the Queen don't
forget about her she's important you
have a check another check we're gonna
care less about our G pond we're
crashing through here
is uh he could he could run fast I'm
gonna check check there you never check
they're here and then there
it's how he drew it up a check here
there
okay 34 28 I'm back six mmm I need to
get two games in this guy needs to lose
he's in the middle of a game it appears
that I'm not gonna catch that guy okay
let's try this takes I'll go Knight g6
let's go here right away
oh okay
take my knight are you gonna take them I
guess here let's keep pressure on this
pawn I'm gonna look for Knight g6 maybe
oh no I forgot about that move can I run
away we're gonna find out we are gonna
find out 96 super defender um work
yourself into a pin why not
it's the danger what's the big problem I
could rely upon my knight on g6 this is
just barely working barely take there um
right here let's take him out hang on
careful now that's that's a free they
had that Bishop 12 seconds
mmm they have this okay can my night be
dangerous eight seconds oh he's
dangerous he's a dangerous man that
night is extra dangerous so I have
dangerous night 35 seconds that's gonna
be the last one thirty eight thirty two
twenty nine okay yeah I'm not gonna get
paired up again he had a couple speed
bumps but Iowa no that's me he didn't
have any speed bumps flawless victory
very nice how did I get out of that last
game no idea
Ajay's I had a better chance in the
first encounter with this guy around 2
though got that c-file pressure was too
much
all right to the 152 of you who know how
to play honestly good games all
you